okay hi everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a
for kids and others and we seem to
always get a lot of very interesting
questions
um we can i i'm happy to try and address
a diversity of questions about
science it's history technology it's
history different areas of science
et cetera et cetera et cetera but i
noticed we still have a bunch of
questions left over
from last time i didn't have a chance to
address
so let's see let's pick one of these
there's a question here from icy
uh why is it that the sunspot cycle is
important for shortwave radio
gosh you guys throw me all sorts of
strange questions all right let's see if
i can
address that so first question is what
is the sunspot cycle
so if you look at the sun and like it's
a bad idea to like
look at the sun with your own eyes but
um if you
uh like use a little pinhole camera if
you make a little pinhole in a
piece of paper you can project an image
of the sun
on onto something and you can kind of
indirectly look at
what's on the sun or you can look
through very dark glass and look at the
sun
if you look carefully really you kind of
need to use a telescope to do this
properly
um you will see that the sun which looks
like just this bright disk to us usually
actually has a bunch of dark spots on it
called sunspots
and there's this cycle that roughly is
an 11-year cycle
of how many uh sun how many spots
the sun has on at any given time you can
go look it up actually more from alpha
you can go say how many sunspots are
there on the sun right now it'll change
from week to week month to month
um they'll be it'll range from i don't
know maybe
as close to zero up to tens of of spots
okay so what are these things these are
essentially
magnetic storms in the atmosphere of the
sun
and um the sun is mostly
this hot glowing um
ball of gas the um the center of the sun
is very hot like 10 million degrees
the surface of the sun is much colder
like 6000 degrees
um and uh but on the surface of the sun
there's
there's a sort of a layer of um uh of
plasma
that is um uh essentially a hydrogen gas
where the electrons have been stripped
out and so on kind of like
kind of a big ball of literally fire
fire is also
um what we see in fire is also a plasma
but so the surface of the sun
is uh the the um there's a sort of
atmosphere layer just like
of um uh of of kind of progressively
more dilute
um plasma on the surface of the sun and
just like the earth has uh patterns of
winds and
other things and you can have hurricanes
and things on the surface of the
uh on the in the earth's atmosphere so
you can have similar kinds of
magnetic storms in the in the in the
um uh electrically and magnetically
charged
um magnetic uh sort of atmosphere of the
sun
and you know there are these kind of
giant storms that take place in other
places too like in jupiter for example
there's the great red spot of jupiter
that's been there for at least 400 years
or so
that is a giant storm kind of about the
size of the earth because jupiter is
much bigger than the earth so
that um and that spot um gradually
moves around and gradually changes its
character sunspots are kind of the same
kind of idea
but they are a sort of a some kind of
um uh thing that's a bit like a
hurricane
but operating in this uh plasma
atmosphere of the sun
okay so one issue with sunspots is that
when there is this kind of activity in
the in the
uh sort of atmosphere of the sun the sun
tends to
spew out more and more charged particles
so so usually the sun you know what we
most see about the sun is the light it
produces
but there's also electrons and protons
that that are being uh that are sort of
being
uh emitted from the sun just as the sun
is emitting photons of light
it's also producing a stream of
electrons and and protons
and that the primary part of that stream
is the so-called solar wind
um which is this this this flow of of
electrons and protons out from the sun
okay so
the solar wind is the the amount of it
depends on um
uh the um uh the the
depends on what's going on in the in the
atmosphere of the sun and there are
these
so-called coronal mass ejections which
are
things that are somehow associated with
this kind of storm-like
structures in the in the atmosphere of
the of the sun
i'm not sure how how completely this is
understood i i have not um
uh lost i looked at it which is probably
um
through maybe a few decades ago by now
um it was not well understood whether
there is a better understanding of it
now i'm not sure
um but there's been as i say there's an
11-year cycle i don't think that cycle
is well understood
and they're also a longer range uh
changes like um
in the mid 1600s there was a period when
there weren't sunspots for a long time
it also corresponded to a period
a very cold climate on the earth and
it's conceivable
that the amount of of heat and light
produced by the sun
actually is also somehow related to
these features of the atmosphere of the
sun and
the number of sunspots okay so what does
any of this have to do with radio on the
earth
well so from the sun there's a solar
wind varying amounts of electrons and
protons
that are emitted from the sun that
stream outwards from the sun
and a bunch of those just like light
from the sun reaches the earth so also
those electrons and protons from the sun
reach the earth
okay so what happens to your average
electron or proton
that's uh uh approaching the earth from
the sun
depends a bit on how fast they're going
how energetic they are
there's a definite um uh
spectrum of energies just like for light
from the sun light from the sun tends to
be concentrated around a certain range
of wavelengths
that make the sun look white to us
because it just has mostly has
um it's it's it's concentrated in this
um
black body spectrum planck spectrum uh
with a peak
um somewhere in the in the middle of the
visible light range
um in the case of uh the charged
particles electrons and protons
it's a slightly different distribution
of uh of energies
i think the um uh the the
oh let's see in in the units used by
particle physicists
um one gev uh one billion
electron volts um is a common energy
uh for protons from the sun but any case
protons electrons from the sun
come out they get to the vicinity of the
earth what happens
to your average proton that's
approaching the earth okay well
there's another complicated thing the
earth has a so-called magnetosphere
and um the because the earth has a
magnetic field
um that is produced by uh currents
in the in the liquid core of the earth
um the electric currents
essentially in the liquid core of the
earth produce a magnetic field which
which is mostly like the field of a
giant bar magnet that would be in the
earth
from the with with one end at the north
magnetic pole of the earth the other end
south magnetic pole of the earth
that produces a um
uh that has has the effect of
of um uh of producing this magnetic
field
and when you have a charged particle
that's moving
a magnetic field exerts a force on that
charged particle
just like when you have electricity and
static electricity
electrical electric
things that are electrically charged if
they're charged
alike they'll repel if they're charged
oppositely they'll attract
um when you have something when you have
a magnetic field
it has an effect on an electrically
charged thing
its effect is a little different than
the effect of an electric field the
magnetic field the effect
is proportional to the velocity of the
particle
and it's also in the direction so if the
if the if the particle is moving in some
direction the magnetic field is going in
some direction
if those two things are right angles the
actual force is at yet another right
angle in the in the
in sort of the third dimension so to
speak but any case the the main
point is that when a um
when a charged particle uh interacts
with a magnetic field
it's deflected um there's a force um
associated with a magnetic field that
deflects the particle okay
so your average particle from the sun is
approaching the earth
let me not talk about the magnetosphere
let me just talk about what happens when
the charged particle from the sun
interacts with the magnetic field of the
earth which is kind of like this bar
magnet thing
the main thing that happens is that
these particles will spiral in towards
the earth they'll be sort of
they'll be the forces associated with
this magnetic field will trap the
particles
and uh they'll they'll form they'll
they'll move in these kind of spirals
and they will tend to move towards the
north and south magnetic poles of the
earth
and so particles from the sun they'll
all be pulled in
to the earth's magnetic field and and uh
and
and spiral in okay what significance
does that have
well um uh gosh there's a lot of steps
to this
the okay so the
a charged particle that is um
uh being uh
being deflected being essentially a
charged particle
that has a force acting on it and that
is as a result accelerating
so when when something in order to keep
something going around in a circle
you have to say it's got to change the
direction of its
motion continuously so that it keeps
going around the circle if it didn't
change its direction emotion
will go in a straight line in order to
change the direction of motion
you are making the thing accelerate in a
certain direction
so another feature is that when a
charged particle accelerates
it emits uh um
it radiates an electromagnetic field
so an electromagnetic wave so that means
when
it's just a a rule about about the way
electromagnetism works
if you take a charged particle and you
uh
accelerate it it will
generate a um uh um uh
uh electromagnetic radiation um
and uh in particular if you have a
charged particle going around a circle
there's a particular kind of
electromagnetic radiation called
synchrotron radiation
that is produced that's associated with
it it's
it's true of any acceleration but if you
have it going around a circle there's
just particular characteristics that
that radiation has
and this is electromagnetic radiation so
like radio waves
um not nuclear radiation um in any case
so
particles spiraling in around the north
and south magnetic poles
produce electromagnetic radiation that
essentially means that they're producing
radio waves and so if you are
uh if you have your radio receiver tuned
to something around the frequency of
those radio waves
you will essentially hear the um uh the
effect of all those particles that came
from the
came from the sun we're in the solar
wind we're captured by the earth's
magnetic field we're spiraling around
the earth's magnetic field
but producing radiation you get to
detect that radiation with your radio
and that's what happens in shortwave
radio i mean i i
remember at least when i was a kid i
somehow radios today don't don't usually
are usually set up with nice digital
stuff and so on you don't really get to
tune it to a certain frequency and
certainly not those kinds of frequencies
um but uh um you can
you can hear all these all these funny
noises that are very
uh um sort of uh
spacey sounding noises that are
essentially the radio turning the that
election those radio waves
into sound that you can hear um and
that's
um and that's that's how uh there's an
effect from
from um uh from the solar wind on
and particles from the sun on radio
and as i mentioned the um uh the the the
amount of solar wind depends on among
other things
um the the number of sunspots in the sun
now another effect
of um uh these charged particles
spiraling
in um around the north magnetic south
magnetic poles is the aurora
so if you've been at um sufficiently
northern
or presumably southern although there's
a lot less land there and people don't
go there as often
if you go to kind of uh fairly northern
uh somewhere in canada or something like
this
and it's uh sufficiently dark and it's
typically in the wintertime so it's
it's some you know dark a longer part of
the day
and you let your eyes get very dark
adapted um
you'll probably see uh
an aurora or you may see an aurora the
amount of the aurora depends on the
number of charged particles
that are um that are coming into towards
the earth from the sun
uh what the aurora looks like it kind of
looks like this giant kind of
curtain-like
structure across the sky um and uh if
you let your eyes get really dark
adapted you may start seeing it in color
in typically reds and greens and things
like that what is the aurora
the aurora is the effect of those
charged particles from the sun
interacting with the upper atmosphere of
the earth and in particular
they the charged particles are producing
um are interacting with things like
oxygen
um in the upper atmosphere of the earth
and
the when a charged particle
um oh boy another another level of
physics i have to explain here
um what's happening is
that uh you have an atom of oxygen for
example
it has electrons that are in that atom
and the the if the atom
is somehow given more energy
those electrons will uh they have a
certain
set of energy levels that they can exist
at
and that's one of the consequences of
quantum mechanics
is that in an atom the set of possible
energies for the electrons in the atom
uh are a discrete set so if you just
have
a um i don't know a planet orbiting a
star
the planet can orbit at any distance
from the star it can have
any amount of kinetic energy as it moves
around in its orbit
but when you look at very small things
like electrons and atoms that's not true
anymore
and what quantum mechanics kind of
showed
from the 1910s to 1920s type period
is that in fact instead of there being a
continuous set of possible energies for
the electrons in an atom
there's a discrete set okay so what
well the when an atom
produces uh
when an atom produces if you if you
somehow get the electron to go from
its lower energy state to a higher
energy state then
after after a while the electron
may make a transition back to the low
energy state
and in doing so it uses up the energy
that it went to that
that it lost by going to the lower
energy state it uses that up by emitting
a photon
and so one of the things that happens is
that when you excite atoms
of a particular element there will be a
discrete set of so-called spectral lines
a discrete set
of frequencies essentially different
colors of light
that are emitted and you can detect that
by
using a prism or a diffraction grating
or something like that you can see it
particularly
in like fluorescent light bulbs you see
a very distinct spectrum
of um of of of lines
of places where there are particular
energies particular colors
that are produced um by that gas
well it's the same thing in the aurora
the excitation of
things like oxygen and nitrogen in the
upper atmosphere
they are uh they are given energy
by these charged particles from the sun
and then
they as they uh sort of
as the as that energy is dissipated from
those atoms
it's emitted in the form of photons of a
certain frequency and those frequencies
correspond to kind of reds and greens
and so on
and that's um that's what you see in the
aurora so what you're seeing in the
aurora
is kind of a map of of where there are
charged particles that are exciting
atoms in the upper atmosphere and then
those atoms in the upper atmosphere are
emitting light
which we get to see as the aurora and
that's um that's kind of the um
uh it's a feature of the fact that there
are all these charged particles that are
being captured
by the magnetic fields of the earth
which is most intense
near the north and south magnetic poles
um and that's
um and that's that's what causes the
aurora okay that was a surprisingly long
answer i i have to say i'm i'm
it's always one of the things that's
really interesting about um
doing these q as is that um uh
it's like there are questions where i
say to myself
that's a fairly straightforward physics
question i kind of know the answer to it
and i realize
there's five or ten different steps that
have to be gone through
to explain it so that was a that was a
longer one than i was initially
expecting
um
let's see
um
all right there's a um
a question from
michael here what aspects of the origin
of life
would be interesting to investigate with
current computing tools
okay interesting question so
uh first question is what is life
and what would count as having got
something that we consider to be alive
you know on on earth everything that's
alive
has for example rna in it all the
bacteria
even viruses um there well viruses can
be rna or dna viruses but
but basically everything uses this
genetic code idea
that's encoded in rna and dna everything
uses proteins and amino acids
there's a lot of chemistry that is in
common between different um
between all the life that exists on
earth now maybe
when life was originating on earth there
were five competing
versions of chemistry for life and only
the particular one that involved dna and
amino acids and so on
survived and there were other ones that
just died out we don't know
um but one question we can ask is the
particular example that we have of life
on earth involves this particular
collection of chemical processes
now if we ask abstractly what is life
that's a much harder question
if we ask if we say well you know how do
you how could you tell
when for example you look at you know
soil on mars or you
you dig down in you know the oceans of
europa or something
or if uh one of the popular things right
now if you look at um
the clouds on venus you know what would
allow you to tell whether that
complicated chemical process that's
happening in the clouds on venus or
something
whether that counts as life or not and
people have tried for a long time to
make sort of abstract definitions of
life it's never really worked very well
in fact i don't think it's possible to
make such a definition people say
something is alive if for example it can
reproduce itself
but now think about something like fire
fire once you have a piece of fire
it can sort of reproduce itself or if
you say
um uh well and you say well if it can't
reproduce itself then it's not alive
well you know you think of something
like a mule which happens to have been
been set up so it doesn't happen to be
able to reproduce itself but it's
most definitely a pretty alive creature
so
so these kind of abstract definitions
that people come up with have never
really worked
there are a variety of other ones that
involve kind of life
is something that sort of takes its
environment in the form of food and
things like this
and turns its kind of disorganized
environment
into the actual organized structure of
the organism so to speak again
there are plenty of systems that do that
so so these abstract definitions don't
work very well
but the particular instance of life that
we have on earth
has these particular chemistry and
particular chemical processes
that that characterize it so the
question is how did that all get started
and how did you go from kind of a um
uh just the earth with a bunch of you
know
random chemicals on it to something
which had all the features of modern
life so to speak
and uh could we for example recognize
that process happening in the clouds on
venus
what would it look like uh there's a lot
we don't know
about how life originated on on earth
um i think there are certainly there's
different questions about what came
first for example
cells the fact that you've got this
collection of chemicals that are all
uh sort of all having reactions together
all inside this this skin effectively
around a biological cell um it could be
that
cells were an early thing to happen that
they sort of made the little
test tubes effectively that allowed
chemical processes to go on in a more
effective way
in the early earth than um uh than
uh than otherwise i mean the the general
belief is that life
originated in the early oceans of the
earth
in liquid phase uh possibly life
originated in something slightly more
exotic
like one of these sort of um uh
hydrothermal vent
type things where you have somewhat
exotic temperatures and
gradients of temperatures and and
somewhat exotic chemicals and so on
or or possibly it originated in
something that
um is
just just purely but but the general the
general thought is that it's probably
originated in liquid phase um and
because the liquid allows you to have
lots of chemical reactions happening and
lots of things mixing together if you
have a solid
things just don't move very much so not
much can happen if you have a gas
things don't kind of there isn't quite
the the level of amount of reaction that
can happen in liquid so
probably a liquid is the thing now you
know so what came first would the cell
come first that sort of provided the
test tube in which other things can
happen
did what originated things like rna and
dna
and these kind of biological molecules
that are capable of storing
information that can be sort of
genetically transmitted from one
one uh one
one generation to the next we don't know
there's a possible thought that clays
were involved where you have a
a surface of clay and maybe maybe the
maybe you could
essentially just have instead of having
this molecule
dna for example that on which you can
put
information somehow on the surface of
the solid surface of clay
and i said everything was happening in
liquid phase but maybe solids were
important
because maybe you could kind of deposit
the sort of template
for your living system on this clay
that would then stay constant even as
the sort of chemicals swirl around but
we don't know
now in terms of can we investigate this
kind of thing with um
with tools that we have well uh we can
sort of try and make computational
models
of what would be involved in a process
uh where one goes from this kind of uh
when where one generates something sort
of as complicated as
a self-reproducing molecule um which is
what uh
well dna is not on its own it's
self-reproducing molecule it needs
all the apparatus of um uh that exists
in cells to to be able to actually
reproduce itself
um actually i mean i've done a bunch of
computer experiments
um on looking at um uh
looking at the sort of emergence of
complicated behavior
from from very simple rules and very
simple sort of random initial conditions
it's a little hard to conclude all that
much
because it really depends on this
question what is the fundamental
definition of life
you know you're not really simulating
actual amino acids and actual
detailed chemicals you've got something
much more idealized
and the question is when you've got that
idealized thing what feature do you
point to and says yes
i just got something that was sort of
counts as a living system that emerged
from this
now one of the things that's interesting
is is life how common is life
if you have the early earth with all the
molecules it had and all the different
processes that are going on
is it sort of almost inevitable that
you'll end up with
some form of life that you'll end up
with a particular form of life that we
have with dna and things like that
nobody knows the answer to this
nobody knows whether this is sort of a
very rare thing
that only happens in very uh you know
by a great chance you know with a chance
of one
one you know one chance out of a
trillion trillion children traveling
trillion
or whether it's much more common i think
the general belief is
it's probably fairly common now the
question is
how many completely disparate forms of
life-like stuff could you get
the answer is probably very large and
maybe many of them would not be
recognizable
as something that we would say is like
life because when we talk about life
we think about the particular instance
of life that we have here on earth
so the question is what's the chance
that something sort of reasonably close
to life as we have it on earth
would arise elsewhere uh we don't know
the answer to that
i mean one of the things that may be a
very confusing feature
is life is very good at replicating
itself so
you know if you just have some meteorite
that um
uh let's say originated on the earth and
had a little piece of something
you know bacteria or something or um
uh these uh tardigrades which live a
really long time
in very um very uh uh
in in without any nutrition or with and
without even
atmosphere or whatever else you know if
these things hit your ride on a
meteorite
you can end up going a very long way
across the solar system or even across
the galaxy
um and uh and end up spreading
the particular form of life that for
example we have
to somewhere quite different so if we
suddenly discovered that on europa for
example there's life that's just like
what we have on earth
i think it's vastly more likely that it
got that way
because it got physically transported
there
some some seed effectively got
physically transported there
then that life in the particular form
that we have here on earth
uh would originate in two different
times even within the same solar system
so that's a little bit on on that
ah gosh
all right um
well i've got a question here about um
from pranjul
um how does 3d printing work
and what is its potential okay
fundamental idea of 3d printing is you
make stuff
by incrementally adding things so
a lot of manufacture of objects
you will like a a typical sort of piece
of
a plastic object or something you'll
make a mold
usually out of metal you'll pour pour
liquid plastic into that mold
and then the the and then the plastic
will solidify
in the shape that corresponds to that
mold you take the mold off you've got
your plastic thing
okay that's that's sort of a traditional
way to make a plastic object
is you have a mold that gives you the
that defines the shape
for what's initially liquid plastic and
ends up
that ends up solidifying producing the
shape you want okay
a 3d printer instead builds that piece
of plastic that plastic object
incrementally so it literally has a
thing that is essentially squirting out
little tiny pieces of plastic
and it keeps on just adding tiny pieces
of plastic to something that's growing
growing growing growing growing
and a typical technology typically
it'll it'll grow it in layers so you'll
see it it'll have this little print head
that's running around and it's adding
little pieces of plastic on one layer
and then
adds pieces of plastic on the next layer
and the next layer the next layer
and pretty soon you've built an object
that's so-called additive manufacturing
so to speak where you're just
progressively
adding pieces on to the object you're
growing and
um you can uh so both
with a mold there's a limitation on the
kinds of shapes you can make in a mold
because if if you're going to have the
plastic go into
this shape then you want to pull the
mold apart
after pull the mold away after you've
made the plastic
there are there are ways you can have
sort of little spokes pointing out of
the plastic we just couldn't pull the
mold apart
if the plastic had solidified in that
shape without breaking the plastic
well in the case of 3d printing there
are
less limitations on the shapes that you
can make
the the only kinds of basic limitations
are
if you're making the thing and you're
you're sort of growing it additively
from its base it better not be the case
that there's a thing that's floating in
space
where you you specified in your computer
some geometry
that just says and now we want this
sphere that doesn't have anything to
support it you always need supports
that um allow you to sort of grow up
from the supports now maybe
you build the supports and then you
remove the supports when you finish
building it
you know it's interesting when you look
at the growth of of organisms and
biology
um there are always different tricks
that organisms have to use to grow the
shapes they grow
so for example huge difference between
plants and animals
uh you know plants have rigid cell walls
made of cellulose and so on
so once they've built a shape they don't
get to change that shape
so a tree for example it's got this
solid you know
wooden trunk so to speak and then it
makes these solid wooden branches
and so trees uh often use this branching
pattern they they make
tree-like branching structures and
that's because
that's a very convenient thing to do if
you can't change your
your shape once you've made it animals
on the other hand are much more squidgy
and um they can they can change their
shape
uh that things can can have their shape
changed even after they're formed
and if you look at the way that
different uh different pieces of
us form there are things where something
will form and then it will fold over
and then it will folds will be pulled
back and so on and so on and so on and
you look at different features of us
whether it's shapes of our ears or our
fingerprints or
all these different kinds of things and
they're all made in different ways like
like for example famously our
our fingers are originally made in a
kind of a sheet of material
where it's like a like a flipper but
then the the cells between the fingers
die off
and that's how the fingers get separated
in in during
um embryo development for for us humans
but so so there are these different
schemes for kind of making
shapes but 3d printing is all about
incrementally making a shape by just
adding one piece
one piece after another and so what do
you do that way you can make all kinds
of shapes
that were not easy to make with molds
and things like that
what can you make those shapes out of
well people started off making them out
of certain kinds of plastic
because that was easier to kind of
squirt out
of a little nozzle to actually uh add
things to it but you can also do 3d
printing with metal
you can do 3d printing with sugar you
can do 3d printing
of all kinds of things and um that's
so one feature is you can make all kinds
of different shapes the other feature is
everything you make is custom made so to
speak
so if you have a mold you've made one
mold and you stamp
out you know thousands millions of
different objects
that are the same shape based on that
mold but in 3d printing
it's just a computer controlling where
that print nozzle is going to go
and so you can have every you could say
let me make
a thousand unique objects each one of
them
is made by um uh by doing
uh by just having the computer move that
printer
printhead around differently now you
know that's the good news the bad news
is i suppose that although 3d printing
has become
it's it's pretty easy to make a 3d
printer these days
um and uh they you can you can get them
made pretty cheaply
they are um the uh
the the the it's still they're kind of a
little messy to use i mean
and you know you end up with little
granules of plastic all over the place
you have to
brush it off and things like this and
and it can be you know if you there's a
bug in your program
that is specifying how to print things
you know the manifestation of bug might
be a bunch of liquid plastic squirting
out of the
print nozzle and all kinds of weird
things can happen
and it's it's been a gradual process to
make 3d printing more and more
straightforward
now other things you can print there are
also many bio medical things that you
can print so
one thing that um
uh is um uh
is is of interest to print is um
things like collagen which are
connective tissue
that is is used in us but it's just
a molecule and you can imagine just sort
of printing collagen in any shape
and then you can use that as a scaffold
to to have actual biological cells form
around it so for example uh
one company i know of is trying to print
uh
3d lungs lungs are this very complicated
tree-like branching structure of maybe
23 levels of tree-like branching and
their idea is to print that
out of collagen then have actual lung
cells be sort of recruited to cover
that collagen scaffold and then you have
something which is essentially an
artificial lung
and so kind of the idea there is to is
to have
things where you can print pieces of
uh that can be used in in biology
where maybe you actually print the final
thing that's going to be used or maybe
you print some kind of scaffold
that's covered with biological cells um
that can then be used
as an actual sort of artificial this or
that uh for biology
but so that's that's kind of one
direction so i think i think the things
about 3d printing
are you can make shapes that aren't easy
to make some other way
you can make one-of-a-kind shapes
easily and you can also potentially make
shapes out of materials that you didn't
otherwise think you could arrange in any
in any particular way so that's kind of
the direction i think there was a
you know 3d printing is really in its
current form as maybe
10 to 15 years old there were sort of
precursors of it going back a long way
but it's been partly uh sort of
precision engineering partly the
computer control
and partly the ability to do
computational geometry and figure out
sort of
how would you make this shape and so on
that's really made 3d printing
sort of come alive i think there was
there's sort of a uh they've been
i think it's it's as in most kinds of
things in manufacturing
it's it's sort of a gradual process to
make it cost effective to do things that
particular way
it's still much more efficient to have a
production line that stamps things out
with molds and so on
than it is to have 3d printers but you
know there are some things like
doing biomedical 3d printing where
you're trying to make
something which will be an artificial
this or that that's the particular shape
needed for a particular person
or where you're trying to make a very
high value thing like you're trying to
make some
uh some complicated shape of turbine
blade that's going to be in
in a jet engine that's going to be that
where you couldn't make it any other way
and where it's going to be a very
expensive object it makes perfect sense
to do that with 3d printing
but you know the sort of revolution of
manufacturing with 3d printing where
instead of having a production line
where things are kind of stamped out
with molds and so on everything is being
3d printed that hasn't happened yet
it may yet happen probably will
eventually happen i think one of the
things that sort of holds it back
is that robotics is still something that
is
uh quite special purpose you know you
have to make a robot for a particular
purpose
we don't have the analog of that we do
with computers we can just have
any computer can take any any program
basically
and do different kinds of computations
we don't have the analogous thing
yet for robotics and that's one of the
one of the pieces that's needed
okay
let's see um
well there's some much more technical
questions here which i i really should
probably do another session there's one
from wave morpher about difference
between
string rewriting systems and l systems
the um
uh i i certainly knew aristotle lindemay
the inventor of l systems
actually strangely those related a
little bit to the thing i was talking
about before
this is an abstract model for how you
can make branching structures
you can take for example you have a rule
that says a
goes to a a and so you make a string
that's a aaa
and then every one of those a's you
replace by two a's
and you kind of trace what happens you
start with single a you make it into two
a's
each of those two a's branches again and
you'll end up with this kind of tree
structure
um that's a thing called a zero l system
um
sometimes or a string substitution
system um
the uh those kinds of things where you
just take a simple
single character and you turn it into
multiple characters those have been
quite well studied
um the the case that is uh more like the
string substitution systems that that i
tend to use
um have to do with with taking blocks of
letters
and rewriting those and then taking
blocks of letters and rewriting them in
all possible ways
and that's a little different i suppose
you could think of it as a
non-deterministic
uh arbitrary l system where k kl
system where where instead of having a a
thing which
uh just uh yeah this is getting very
technical i think
is for a different for a different um
different discussion
um
let's see questions here
about oh my gosh
um
okay all right so there's a question
here from daniel
how do you think like a mathematician or
a scientist
i've read and heard that math and
science take a different mental process
than what we are shown at school what
skills should i be building
okay so that's interesting so
doing research in math and science is a
little bit of a different process
than learning the tools of math and
science
and quite a lot what tends to be done in
school
is learning the tools to be able to use
what people already figured out in math
and science
and when you do research what you're
trying to do is figure out things people
haven't figured out before
you're trying to build new math and
science and that's a little bit of a
different process
than than making use of the math and
science that's already been built
now needless to say when you try and
build new math and science
it's good to build on top of math and
science that's already been built
to make use of the tools that come from
existing math and science
i think that um well let's take math and
let's take science separately
for the way that they're taught uh in
particular k through 12 schools
um i think that there is uh there are
kind of
well there's different kinds of things
when when you learn math
you're learning um you're learning a
variety of things you're learning
uh sort of things about how to think
precisely about anything
you're learning particular methods that
have been found useful
in actually doing the math that people
have found useful and maybe you're
learning a little bit
about the sort of cultural tradition of
mathematics
and the kinds of things that people have
been able to figure out mathematically
those are those are separate kinds of
things to learn
um i think what you're not particularly
figuring out is to how to build new
mathematics for example
um i would say that the one essential
feature of sort of thinking like a
mathematician
is just thinking in a precise
organized way about things so you know
give you an example there's a good kind
of mathy thinking kind of question
so let's say you're going to number the
the corners of a square
okay okay how do you do it well
you might say let's go you know around
the square one two three
four okay reasonable way to do it now
let's say you've got a cube
how do you number the corners of a cube
there's no right answer to how to do
this
but you could just say well i'll just
put one number here and i'll put another
number there and i'll
just fill in numbers until i've got all
the all the corners of the cube
numbered but actually there are much
more systematic ways to do it
you'd think about oh i don't know you
think about each
each thing as a coordinate in three
dimensions and then you convert that to
a single
a single integer or whatever else that
there are variety of ways to do it or
you make a path where you're going
around the cube in an organized way
so sort of thinking mathematically is
about
kind of how to organize your thoughts
so that you you make things you think
about things systematically
that that's that's a big part of it um i
think that
the the question of sort of how you um
of the actual methodology of doing
mathematics how do you
you know add fractions how do you work
out an integral
these kinds of things there's a certain
set of systematic methods that people
have invented
and there's a lot of little tricks that
work in this case or that case or the
other case
um it's very useful to learn how to do
anything precisely
those particular tricks probably aren't
super useful um and in fact
you know when you say well how does a
computer do an integral work out you
know fractions in
in lowest terms or whatever else the
methods it uses
are actually rather different from the
methods we humans use
the methods we humans tend to be taught
to use involve the
noticing the little special shortcut
that can happen for this particular
exercise
the computer doesn't do that the
computer has an algorithm maybe we
programmed that algorithm
um that is like a big industrial machine
that just says
given any integral of this type grind
grind grind i can turn it into this very
complicated formula
more complicated than humans would ever
want to deal with but i'm just a
computer so i can deal with that
complicated formula
and it comes back down it produces
something which humans find useful
but but so uh i think
the um so that's one thing another thing
that's very useful to learn in
mathematics
is kind of just what's known in
mathematics you know they're these ideas
like prime numbers
prime numbers come from antiquity they
were you know they've been around a long
time but it's like the idea of a prime
number is an interesting idea
um the idea of kind of something like
topology
that's a much more recent idea roughly
120 years old
um but that's an idea you know how many
holes does this
does this object have independent of the
overall the shape of the object what is
its topological structure how many
you know what does it is it like a
doughnut with a hole in the middle or is
it
is it like a blob like a sphere so to
speak um that's another kind of idea
that comes from mathematics and there's
a there's a series of these ideas
that are in some level not very
difficult to understand
if you want to sort of do topology and
be a professional topologist
that's a whole layer of complexity but
the basic idea of topology is kind of a
cultural idea
is something that you can definitely get
access to
and i think some part of what's done in
mathematics education
tends to be uh well partly because of
the kind of structure of education and
assessment and all this kind of thing
quite a lot of it tends to be sort of
this quite mechanical you know now
you've got schemes for working out
adding fractions
go add 200 fractions together so to
speak um
and uh that's you know that that's sort
of different from this question of sort
of
culturally learning what are the
important things that are known in
mathematics
now when it comes to science uh
different fields of science you know in
physics for example you can expect to do
in ecuador chemistry
that they have been mathematicized
enough to the point where you can
actually expect given a particular
physics scenario you can expect
to predict what will happen um the uh
that's not really true in biology
biology is much more you know
given given the existence of elephants
can you predict the rhinoceros no you
can't
um that they're actually i have more
things to say about that particular
issue
and there is some degree of
predictability but but it's not
something that's accessible
at the level of of learning kind of
school biology
and there it's much more just there are
these facts about the way biology works
and there are some inferences that you
can make from from the fact that biology
works in this way so it implies this and
this and this
but there's not the same kind of depth
of formal structure that exists in
mathematics or in
physics or to some extent in chemistry
now i mean
you know when you when you start sort of
doing research about things
uh you know research is about answering
questions that haven't been answered
before building structures that haven't
been built before
the the place that i think is the is the
great growth area for
that and the in our times is computation
and you know i've spent a large part of
my life
trying to build this sort of full-scale
computational language
that allows you to take things you think
about
and make them computational and then get
a computer to help you do them
so whether it's dealing with chemistry
uh and dealing with the kind of graph
structures of molecules
and being able to figure out uh you know
the three-dimensional structure of the
molecule and so on
given what you might think about as sort
of the graph structures of molecules or
whatever
that's the kind of thing that you know
how old from language system
knows how to do intrinsically it already
knows a lot of the knowledge that you
might have had to learn
uh painstakingly sort of in in
in school it's automating those kinds of
things and it's letting you kind of
concentrate on
on thinking about so what do you want to
figure out
but part of explaining to it what you
want to figure out you have to be able
to formulate your thoughts
in a computational way uh it's the same
same thing with mathematics you know
you've got some word
problem of you know if if if jane has
seven marbles and
and bill takes away three marbles you
know how many marbles are left okay or
some more complicated version of that um
you've got to be able to take that
description in words and turn it into a
sort of mathematical equation
type of thing so similarly when you have
some question
about um oh i don't know geography or
whatever else you know
what's the what's the capital city
that's furthest from an
ocean in the world okay that's a
question
you can sort of formulate that
computationally what does it mean to be
furthest from an ocean on on the given
that the earth is spherical you know is
that
is that the distance on the surface of
the sphere is that the distance through
the sphere
those kinds of things once you've
formulated that question
in a clear computational way then it's
the job of people like me to provide
automation to actually get that question
answered by the computer so to speak
but learning how to formulate things in
a computational way
is is an important is an important thing
and that's kind of
i think probably the top you know 21st
century skill that still only a fairly
small number of people have
and that's the top kind of thing to aim
for is you know how do you understand
how to formulate things in computational
language that allows you to do
computational x where x is pretty much
any field you can imagine doing
now in terms of the process of doing
research
the there's there's given a question how
do you answer the question
and there's how do you come up with a
question so what i've been addressing in
terms of thinking computational terms
and so on
is particularly oriented towards once
you have the idea of a question
how do you formulate it in such a way
that you can answer it with the help of
a computer perhaps
the other thing is how do you come up
with a good question well actually
thinking computationally provides a way
to do
to help with that as well because
thinking computationally
allows you to to kind of have a way to
form your thoughts
so that you can kind of make inferences
from your thoughts without even using a
computer just by virtue
of the kind of organization of your
thoughts that sort of turning them into
something computational provides
but in general the um uh the
the thing to do is think about you know
given something you're studying in
school
question is what questions can you ask
about it i mean it's it's kind of like
what you guys are doing with me here you
know it's like
what questions do you want to ask you
learned something about
some particular area of i don't know
biology chemistry physics mathematics
whatever
it's like okay what do you wonder about
based on what you learned
what is it that wasn't answered by what
you learned now
the thing you wonder about might be
something that oh well the teacher will
cover it next week it's all rather easy
or oh yeah you'll get to that at some
point in high school mathematics
or it might be like oh well you know if
you do graduate school mathematics you
might get to it
or it might be something where sorry
human civilization has not yet answered
that
question and what's remarkable
is that particularly when you start
thinking computationally
you very quickly get to questions you
very quickly are led to formulate
questions
where it's in the sorry nobody's
nobody's figured that out yet
perhaps because nobody formulated that
question before
um and uh you know even in mathematics
they're questions about numbers
that are really very easy to formulate
uh well they're questions that are
famous that people formulated like are
there an infinite number of twin primes
primes like 11 and 13 that are just two
apart nobody knows the answer to that
question
people have worked on that question a
lot that question is really hard at
least in the current stage of
mathematics
but there are plenty of questions you
can ask in mathematics where you say
imagine you've got some sequence like
i'll give you one that i
i just was looking at okay so you've got
um
you've got a sequence you've got um a
function f
of n n is an integer so so you might say
you know the fibonacci sequence a famous
sequence where f of n
is equal to f of n minus one plus f of n
minus two
that sequence if you if you start from
zero and one for example
the the successive values of f of one f
of two f of three for four f of five
are one one two three five eight
uh 13 21
i should know the fibonacci numbers um
each one is just made by that formula
okay so uh take the formula instead of
the fibonacci formula take the formula
um f of n is equal to three times
f of n minus
f of n minus one so the f of n minus one
is inside
the um it's it's f of n minus f of n
minus one
okay uh i have no idea what the sequence
of values produced by that is i've
i've looked at it on a computer it jumps
around all over the place it's really
wild it's really random
and we know nothing about it and you
know
that's not a particularly complicated
question to formulate
um but it's something which is you know
that's a frontier research question
where we know nothing so far and it's
quite possible that you know maybe
maybe there's actually something pretty
obvious if you look at it in the right
way maybe there's something
that is obvious in the sense that
doesn't require
a lot of elaborate mathematical
knowledge to figure it out maybe it's
something that if you know you know
algebraic k
theory it will help you in figuring out
the answer to this question
um but uh you know but that's sort of
the essence of research is is like what
are the questions
um you know and then then if you do
research for a while
you know one of the things that if you
uh
well which the best people kind of get
good intuition for
is what kinds of questions need what
level of difficulty of answer
what kinds of questions are likely to be
oh that's pretty easy you can get there
pretty
pretty straightforwardly and what kinds
of questions are likely to be big deep
complicated things and then what kinds
of methods might be useful
for answering those questions but that's
kind of the um
you know when you do research the um
it's kind of a
uh you know you have a question like the
one i just phrased that
just just described and it's like i
don't really know
how difficult that question is i have
certain ideas
et cetera et cetera i know that by doing
computer experiments i can make some
progress on that question so i know
that there's in terms of planning the
research i know there's a certain amount
i can figure out
whether i'll be able to crack the
question and say yes i really understand
i can really prove what's going on in
the sequence i don't know
but i can get i've got i've got kind of
a direction to go in doing computer
experiments i've got some definite thing
to do
it's always bad in research we get to
the point where it's like i don't know
at all what to do next there's no
obvious thing to do next
uh in my experience if there's no
obvious thing to do next do a computer
experiment and try and look at
particular examples try and actually
make it concrete what you're doing
and look at examples even if those
examples are a kind of very
junior compared to the full question
you're trying to ask
but but those are some some uh some
things now you know
i would say that that um uh sort of
being able to do research successfully
uh you know to really push the frontiers
you have to be good at figuring out what
questions to ask
and that's not something that they teach
you in school
um and i think the way uh you know i
i think people are kind of born with a
good ability to do that
i think people get distracted from their
ability to ask good questions
by being told repeatedly that's not a
good question
and i just don't think that's a i think
you know every question is a reasonable
question
it may be easy to answer or maybe really
hard to answer um
but you know you can you can look at all
of them so to speak
and i think also in terms of the uh you
know doing research
uh being proficient with tools
particularly computational language in
in modern times is the single most
important tool
to be proficient with in doing research
in pretty much any area now
um and that um and also there's a
there's a question how much you
should you know about what's already
been done about the question you're
you're trying to answer
so one of the things that can happen is
you have a question
like i've been working on a particular
thing last week or two
and i realized there's a huge literature
there's thousands of papers that have
been written about this question
and i might say oh my gosh somebody must
have answered this question before
you know i don't need to look at this
i'll just uh but but
but you know i've looked at enough of
this stuff to know that all these things
are going off in a slightly different
direction
they're saying a lot of things i don't
understand it's like do i have to
understand all this stuff to answer my
question i hope not because it's going
to take a lot of effort
um but uh you know kind of you you might
get to the point where you say
oh my gosh you know i don't want to read
these thousand papers
because they're not really relevant to
what i'm trying to ask and they're all
asking their own questions and i'm going
to get distracted
from what i'm trying to do by reading
them all and it's a complicated thing
you know
i tend to operate on the principle that
i keep my questions kind of clean and
defined by me
i try and do my homework well to
understand what it is that other people
have done
that relates to my particular questions
i don't try i try not to get distracted
by the fact that what other people have
done answers asks different questions
that maybe the methods they've invented
are useful for answering
because that's the way that you kind of
get that's the way you kind of get um
taken off track you know to say well my
question must not be good enough because
these people are asking other kinds of
questions
let me change to asking one of their
kinds of questions no don't do that
stick to the question you had and then
find out to what extent the things that
people have done
can can inform the answer to your
question and do your homework well i
mean i
i tend to work quite hard i'm trying to
understand not only what has been
figured out but also the history of
what's been figured out
because often you you might say to
yourself well i wonder
you know has somebody figured this
particular thing out once you understand
the history of the field
you may realize no nobody will have
looked at that
because at some point in the history of
the field everybody went off in this
other direction and they never
and they and maybe somebody had been
doing this and that direction just died
off
and so so there won't be anything there
and it's it's useful to understand the
history because
it tells you kind of where likely to be
the clumps of knowledge
and where where did people not uh uh not
go
so good question thank you for that um
oh so many questions here
um
let's see
um
there's a question from jonathan here do
you think we could see a day when people
are taught and educated by ai
and computers either with or instead of
people and what do you think of this
especially when compared to education
today
you know when i was a kid which is now a
depressingly long time ago
you know i i always liked reading books
about the future
um and i remember one book in particular
which had this diagram this picture
and it said in the future there will be
teaching machines and that will be the
way that everybody learns things
well it didn't happen and why didn't it
happen
well a couple of reasons i think one
thing
is some people are really pretty good at
just
learning you know first thing is you
have to be motivated to learn stuff i
think
the only way you really learn well is
when you're motivated to learn
and i know that's certainly true for me
i'm probably a particularly bad example
of this because
you know i've learned a lot of different
kinds of things but everything i've
learned i've learned because i cared
about it for some particular reason
you know there was some particular
project i was doing that required me to
know about this
there was some particular uh question
that i was curious about that caused me
to learn about this
and so on and you know it gets easier
after a while because you've learned a
lot of stuff and things start to fill in
and it's like well i'm learning about
this and that relates to these other
three things that i already learned
about
but the fact is that um uh to at least
for me and i may be a particularly bad
example
i'm i'm not you know i'm motivated by
the content of learning about things i
think
other people may be more motivated by
for example the competitive spirit
of i just want to do the best in my
class at all the stuff i'm learning
about for example that's a perfectly
decent motivation
but you have to be motivated in some way
to learn about stuff
and i think that sometimes one can be
sort of abstractly motivated
to the point where you just like i want
to learn about this i'm going to go read
the books
i'm going to go look at the websites i'm
going to go do my computer experiments
whatever else and you're just going to
do them and it's not um
it's not something where somebody has to
sell you on doing them
but some of the rest of the time uh you
know particularly if you're going
through this whole curriculum of what
you might learn in school
some of it you'll care about some of you
won't care about at the time
and some of it frankly has to be sold to
you and that's in a sense a large part
of i think what teaching
ends up being as a human activity is
sort of motivating
the student to um uh to do things
and then a student maybe can have a
particular confusion
and it's like can you navigate that
confusion and say yes this is the thing
you need to know
and you know i i've talked to lots of of
teachers who
who i asked them you know is there a
limited set of confusions that you see
in for example teaching some area of
mathematics and they say well
after enough years teaching yes probably
there is
and it's like okay this person is saying
this this person is getting the wrong
answer this question
this is probably their confusion now you
ask what's the role of things like
ai and so on and doing this that type of
thing
of you got this wrong answer this is
what your confusion is likely to be
that's something that i can imagine we
could automate and in fact we've done
some work on trying to trying to
automate that kind of thing
haven't been uh haven't gotten it to the
point where we have a production ready
system for it um but that's a an
interesting kind of thing
it's the same kind of thing if i wrote a
program it did the wrong thing
what kind of bug might my program have
these are things that i think
there is at least within sort of
striking distance
of being able to use modern artificial
intelligence methods
um to to to answer things about that
another thing that you might ask is for
every one of us humans
there's probably an optimal way to
explain any particular kind of thing
and you know that's based on stuff that
is not readily knowable to somebody else
which is
you know what do i already know like i
was earlier today i was
um uh doing something i don't usually do
i was participating in sort of an
academic conference about
about theoretical physics um and uh
uh you know i'm much more used to
interacting with people where
where it's like somebody's explaining
something to me and i ask them a bunch
of questions and then
they answer those questions and i keep
going and i find that for me that's a
lot easier
than just listening to somebody doing
kind of the broadcast thing of let me
explain to everybody
because my particular way of
understanding it i need to know this
particular thing this particular thing
because those are the things i need to
triangulate from knowledge i already
have
and that will let me understand this
much more quickly i don't need to know
the other 20 minutes of stuff
that um that in fact i already
understand perfectly well but
other people in the audience might might
not know um so
you know i think there's a sense in
which there is one can imagine
being able to sort of target how one
explains things to people based on what
people already know
and you might be able to do something
about what people already know by asking
them a few questions
and then that you know clarifies where
they're coming from so to speak
and then you can kind of um start
explaining uh things in in with a
particular
a sort of trajectory of explanation and
i can imagine that that's something that
is sort of
ai reachable now in terms of what people
learn i mean
you know i i i sort of have a crusade in
a sense in education
you know people felt that education was
too kind of
rote and too much just learn a fact
learn a fact learn a fact learn a fact
and then people said let's teach
principles not facts and then they were
like
well um but we don't need to teach any
facts
and that's just not correct i mean
the you know we know a lot of facts in
our civilization we know a lot of facts
about science we know a lot of facts
about history
we know a lot of facts about a lot of
things and
you as any of us we can't
we can't reinvent the whole history of
mathematics we can't reinvent the
history of science
we can't reinvent you know geography so
to speak we
we have to learn those facts from the
outside world now
how we get motivated to learn those
facts and whether we should learn them
as you know
learn the periodic tables so to speak by
by rote or whatever else
that's a that's a more of a detail but
knowing
that there are facts and actually
learning facts is super useful
because facts are what allow you to
provide sort of the framework
for understanding principles if you try
and understand some abstract principle
without facts
that's really hard to do some people are
better at that than others
people who go into pure mathematics
sometimes are are
or certain kinds of abstract um computer
science and so on
maybe people who are better at the the
understanding of abstract principles
without
without sort of a a framework of facts
although
i think uh even in that i mean i i i
work on a lot of abstract kinds of
things and i think many people would
think of me as a
pretty uh sort of um uh pretty
experienced abstract thinker but the
fact is for me internally i'm really
thinking in very concrete terms
you know it may come out as something
abstract but i'm thinking about this
kind of
symbolic representation of the thing
that's very concrete and
and this you know has this computational
representation and that happens to be
related
to that happens to be understandable in
this very abstract way
but but um so you know i think that
that's a
now you know another question is what is
the subject matter that you should learn
about
in sort of k through 12 education that's
relevant to the modern world
and um you know the the sort of history
of education
the the subject matter has remained
fairly constant for
since education became broadly uh
broadly deployed in 100 and something
years ago it's uh you know
at some level it's kind of reading
writing arithmetic type thing
um somewhat generalized but but it's
it's remained
fairly constant is that the right stuff
to teach
you know i think the the most important
thing that's arisen since the time of
the beginning of public education
is the computational paradigm the idea
of computational language
the idea of thinking about things
computationally that really needs to be
just like literacy in english language
or whatever language you use
um you know the idea of of uh being able
to
think in terms of computational language
just like the idea of thinking in terms
of mathematical language
these are really very important and
useful things and and really critical
skills i think for
for doing lots of things in in the
future but i think that you know it's an
interesting exercise take
your average well i was thinking of
printed encyclopedias but they barely
exist anymore
um but you know take your average big
printed encyclopedia and you look at all
the different categories all the
different subject areas
that exist in there and you ask yourself
which of these do you learn about
in regular school and the answer is it's
maybe one-third
a sort of touched on in some way or
another not necessarily at the depth of
the entire pedia but you know
roughly touched on and there are lots of
other areas you know
you don't tend to learn about i don't
know law or accounting
or medicine for that matter to any any
great extent
or you know lots of areas which are
which are very common areas for people
to
to do as careers you don't actually
learn about and i think
more to the point there are lots of
emerging areas which you certainly don't
learn about because they're just not
part of what um
uh what has been sort of burnt into the
the curriculum
and i think that's a it's an interesting
challenge and question
you know to what extent should one you
know there are things to learn about
that aren't part of standard school
curriculum what do you do about those
i mean it also has to be said that um uh
you know i think a very important piece
as
i keep on sort of repeating you know
this learn the facts
learn the things that our civilization
have learned you know once you know
all that stuff and it includes history
and things like this which you know
history is complicated and it's
it's full of complicated stories you
know told in different ways by different
people etc etc etc but there's
there's it's worth learning history even
though history is complicated
um and uh uh it's it's uh uh
i think the um but you know learning
this kind of base
of sort of what we know as a
civilization
that's that's that's one of the great
things that we
we humans have that's different from
other animals is we get
to actually pass on knowledge from one
generation to another and that has a
large thing
parts to do with the fact that we have
language and so on
um you know you've got to make use of
that in education it's no good
expecting everybody to invent things for
themselves at each generation
you know we might as well be be you know
be antelopes or something if we were
doing that
um that's what that's what other other
organisms have to do but we we have
something better
and we should make use of it all right
let's see i need to go fairly soon here
um
boy there's a question here this is a
pretty abstract one but i'm going to try
and
try and do something with it from
mikhail what is the difference between
science and philosophy
you know always when when you say given
a word given another word
what is their difference what is what is
their relative meaning and so on
obviously words are just
a way of taking a concept that we have
that may change with time and attaching
a label to it
so you know we we can say well what is
the concept that we currently have for
science what's the concept we currently
have for philosophy
how do they differ from each other
historically
the the borders of philosophy and
science have moved quite a bit
i mean in in in you know
physics used to be called in a sense
natural philosophy
what tends to happen is philosophy is an
area
where you're kind of trying to figure
things out from
in a sense nothing from you you are
almost
you're trying to you're trying to say
given some some framework for thinking
about the world
which might be in terms of sort of
axioms of how the world has to be set up
but given something given some basis
that is some quite
abstract and perhaps simple description
of what goes on maybe it's logic maybe
it's something about ethics whatever
given these principles what can we then
just as a matter of sort of logical
inference deduced from these principles
i mean that's that's sort of one slice
of the way one thinks about philosophy
or
or maybe one doesn't start from
principles and build things up maybe one
has
arguments someone has to say how do
these arguments relate to each other
if you believe this can you also believe
that and so on
the people have tried to kind of take
philosophy
and build it up a little bit like one
imagines mathematics is built up
where it really is a very formal thing
where you can sort of get a computer to
do it
go from this step to this step to this
step to sort of build up what's true
um that's not how philosophy has been
successfully done nor i think
is it likely to be but what tends to
happen is philosophy
is arguing about things in a more what
can i say a less
formal way perhaps but still in a sense
a rational way
but not yet a fully pinned down formal
way
it's it's sort of connecting things
together and connecting ideas together
and understanding the relationship
between ideas
and sometimes that understanding of
relationship between ideas
has a very direct consequence for saying
something about the natural world for
instance
now people believed for a long time that
was the only way
to figure out things about the natural
world i mean in ancient greek times
you know your average philosopher had a
theory of physics
you know the world is made from little
icosahedra or the world is made from
this or that
and um you know people at that time
imagined that we would figure out how
the world works what we now call physics
using the sort of pure thought approach
of philosophy
what became clear by the 1600s is that
there are other methods particularly
ones for mathematics
um that allow you to to to make progress
on that now mathematics as i mentioned
is kind of
in some sense conceptually a little bit
like philosophy
but in mathematics it's much more
buttoned down it's much more you have
these axioms you build things up
and you build a giant tower sometimes
you might go on for
for multiple hundreds of years building
theorems upon theorems upon theorems
upon theorems upon theorems
i mean i think one of the things about
philosophy uh you know i say this my
my mother was a philosophy professor
actually um and i always used to kind of
make fun of the fact that um
uh in philosophy people are still
arguing about questions that they were
had raised and discussed two thousand
years ago
in other words it isn't the case that
there's this big stack of things that
have been discovered
and you're sort of building on top of
this giant stack more
the things that plato had to say are
still things that we argue about today
it's it's a much shallower kind of
structure in a sense
and i think that um uh but and so
what happened starting in the 1600s
particularly was that particularly
through mathematics
one was able to build the structure for
science that had this kind of
many many layers of formal structure and
what was able to do things
in philosophy the the main person who
does philosophy is a person
in in sort of the mathematical sciences
by this point
the main mechanism that is figuring out
things as a computer
and i think that the um there's there's
sort of there's
there's layers of of kind of automatable
stuff whereas in philosophy
you're dealing with the things that are
very close to kind of the bedrock of
ideas
now i think that the the other thing
that happened in um but which is sort of
entangled with philosophy
is things like sort of experiments and
looking at the natural world and looking
at computer experiments
these kinds of things and the way that
that informs
one's um one's way of thinking about
things but i think that's
that the really key point is that um
uh one is in philosophy one is really
you know it's just
uh the method of making progress is just
human thought
in these other meth in these other areas
there tends to be the sort of stack of
methodology
and typically what happens is when you
don't have anything else to go on just
use human thought to figure things out
so things get figured out in philosophy
same what happened in natural philosophy
once you have more formal methods you
can transport it and say well now we
have a physics
and we have a mathematical physics and
we have a computational physics
and we can figure things out that way
now it's sort of interesting because
a lot of things transition from
philosophy to other areas
so for example um i know that uh well
i always find it interesting there are
these questions that come up in things
like ethics
and you know the questions of ethics
in the end the self-driving car has to
make an ethics decision
and in the end this thing that has been
debated in philosophy for 2000 years
has to be turned into a piece of code
and so in a sense
the philosophy you have to end the
philosophy and actually turn it into
code at some point
and quite a lot of what i've done in
computational language actually can be
thought of
as sort of a way of thinking about
epistemology and ontology
linguistic philosophy and so on and
concretifying it
in the form of computational language
actually taking
things which were thought of as being
sort of philosophical discussions
and turning them into things where now
we're actually going to make it precise
and make it into a systematic way of
doing things
that we can think of as more like
science um so that that's
and you know for example a big area i
happen to have been involved in recently
is about quantum mechanics
uh there's a certain when you calculate
things in quantum mechanics there's
great physics ways to do it
we can work out all sorts of features of
physical systems by just doing math from
quantum mechanics
but there are some questions of the
interpretation of quantum mechanics
people have been very confused about
and they have turned into philosophy so
to speak people saying what is an
observer what does it mean to observe
a system what does it mean to be an
observer who's in the system that's
being observed
all these kinds of things well now that
we have a much more concrete theory of
physics
that should include all these kinds of
observers and so on we get to take what
was a philosophical question
and actually turn it into something
which is more systematically
formalizable
and it stops being a philosophy question
it becomes a question where you can just
say
the answer is blah and you're not
it's not something where you have to be
reasoning about it and doing things by
pure thought
i mean i i would say that um another
just one other comment about sort of the
the role of philosophy versus uh versus
science
when when we built wolfman alpha uh
it was there was had been a long history
of people trying to use
sort of earlier artificial intelligence
methods to answer general questions
about the world
but their general idea was typically
let's reason about the world to figure
out the answer to a question so
if you ask the question you know um
i don't know uh some question about
whether some object is going to fall
over
um you know it's like well let's reason
about it because it's longer at the top
and shorter at the bottom
then it will fall over or something well
what and
people have found it very difficult to
make a systematic
kind of computational knowledge question
answering system on the basis of that
kind of philosophy style
reasoning approach um which would have
been a sort of a tradition of ai to try
and do those kinds of things
when we built welfare alpha what we did
was say let's just take all the
knowledge
of our civilization which includes
science and mathematics and so on
and yet use that to try and answer
questions and then when you've got some
question about some mechanical object or
whatever
it's like well we just turn it into
equations and we solve the equations
now maybe some philosopher from you know
maybe in the particular case we've given
some philosopher from the 1200s
could have reasoned about this thing and
figured out what would happen but it's a
lot easier
to just use the equations of
mathematical physics that originate in
1600 1700s and so on
just say okay let's jump ahead using
science effectively and answer the
question
so that's a sort of a place where you
see the interplay between between
science and philosophy
now there are questions right now oh
there are questions that i thought were
still philosophy questions
like uh why is it our universe and not
another
can there be more than one universe and
so on i think we've been able to make a
lot of progress in actually answering
that question
um using methods from science and the
answer is there's only one universe
um and uh then then there's a question
which is still
my my kind of philosophy meat science
question that i've been grappling with
which is
uh why does the universe exist can we
prove or disprove the existence of the
universe and my
my current belief is that it may be
possible to prove
that as an entity embedded within the
universe
it is not possible to know uh to prove
that the universe exists
that is that the the proposition the
universe exists
like in girdle's theorem in mathematics
the proposition are more like girdle
second in completeness theorem actually
about the consistency of arithmetic but
um that it's not possible to prove from
within that system
some matter fact about the system like
that it exists
but that's that's a place where for me
at least that's a sort of philosophy
meat science thing of
is that going to be a philosophy
question why does the universe exist or
are we going to
make a science version of it
all right i think i have to um uh
to wrap up here so many interesting
questions i would uh
enjoy um uh chatting about these for
for ages um and uh
yeah well so thanks for joining us
and um i uh look forward to going on and
uh
uh taking uh maybe starting off with
some of the questions i didn't have a
chance to get to today
um next week so thanks a lot